[Music]
we know by now that glycolysis takes
place in the cytoplasm and leads to the
formation of two molecules of pyruvate
per molecule of glucose these pyruvate
molecules are converted into a settle
coenzyme a also known as a settle Co a
and this happens inside the
mitochondrial matrix therefore
acetylcholine etta Baalak intermediate
that links glycolysis and the citric
acid cycle for clarity we will not show
the coenzyme portion of acetylcholine
and instead are simply representing it
as the two carbon molecule acetate so
how does the pyruvate get into the
mitochondrial matrix this depends on a
carrier protein that transports pyruvate
into the mitochondrial matrix where
there it is oxidized to form acetyl co a
by the enzyme pyruvate dehydrogenase in
this reaction a molecule of carbon
dioxide is generated as pyruvate is
oxidized to acetyl co a and a molecule
of nad plus is reduced to NADH this last
reaction is not shown for clarity the
citric acid cycle consists of the
following eight steps and also harvests
chemical energy producing a total of
three NADH molecules in the first step
of the citric acid cycle the enzyme
citrate synthase combines the two carbon
a settle group from a settle Kawai with
the four carbon molecule oxaloacetate
this generates the six carbon molecules
citrate in the second step citrate is
isomerized
into isocitrate by econo tazed in the
third step isocitrate is oxidized by
isocitrate dehydrogenase generating the
five carbon molecule alpha-ketoglutarate
in the process one carbon dioxide
molecule is released and one nad plus
molecule is reduced to NADH in the
fourth step alpha ketoglutarate is
decarboxylated
oxidized to produce another molecule of
carbon dioxide by alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase the resulting molecule is
combined with coenzyme a forming
succinylcholine addition another
molecule of nad plus is reduced to form
NADH note that in this diagram we are
showing the product of this reaction as
succinate and are omitting the coenzyme
a for clarity in the fifth step
succinylcholine xym a is converted into
succinate by succinylcholine that is
releasing coenzyme a this reaction also
produces one molecule of GTP another
high-energy molecule which is emitted
from this diagram for clarity in the
sixth step succinate is oxidized to
fumarate by succinate dehydrogenase
unlike all the other enzymes in the
citric acid cycle succinate
dehydrogenase is embedded in the inner
mitochondrial membrane and is also a
component of the electron transport
chain in which it is also called complex
2 as complex 2 oxidizes succinate it
receives two electrons that it will
ultimately pass on to coenzyme q which
in turn will deliver its electrons to
complex 3 another interesting aspect of
complex 2 is that it uses fa d rather
than nad plus to accept electrons in the
seventh step fumarate is converted to
malate by the enzyme fumarate and
finally in the eighth step the enzyme
malate dehydrogenase oxidizes malate to
reform oxaloacetate and reduces a
molecule of NAD+ to NADH in the process
this regenerated oxaloacetate can then
combine with another acetylcholine in
the next cycle
you
[Music]